[Musique]
bonsoir c'est lors d'auditions publiques
en direct sur lcp public sénat avec le
figaro le confinement est désormais bien
entamée le gouvernement a les yeux
tournés vers la reprise économique
désormais les aides aux entreprises ou
pour le chômage partiel ont déjà coûté
cher 450 milliards d'euros c'est 20 %
des richesses nationales et la note est
loin d'être définitive c'est du jamais
vu mais ça n'empêchera peut-être pas
hélas le chômage d'augmenter
après la crise sanitaire puis les
finances se profile peut-être une crise
sociale
on va parler tout cela avec notre invité
ce soir bonsoir en espagne et une hache
et bonsoir les secrétaires d'état à
l'économie merci d'être sur ce plateau
où vont se succéder à tour de roatan
tran huy et brigitte boucher mes
consoeurs des chaînes parlementaires
puis en duplex deux parlementaires
sophie primas sénatrice et sébastien
jumel députés qui vous parleront par
exemple de la situation chez renault de
la rue relocalisation des entreprises en
france avant de conclure avec yves
thréard directeur adjoint et
éditorialiste au figaro
je vous pose une première question en
cas de deuxième vague de coronavirus
disais que ça coûte coûter cher déjà 450
milliards est ce que la france aurait
les moyens financiers d'y faire face je
crois que l'enjeu c'est précisément
d'éviter une deuxième vague de mios
haddaoui russe et surtout de s'équiper
c'est pour ça que je le rejoins olivier
ferrand lorsqu'il dit que l'épidémie
n'est pas terminée qu'il faut continuer
à appliquer les gestes barrières parce
que nous savons que si l'épidémie
s'emballe alors notre économie et le
risque social augmente donc vous avez
dit on reste très concentré sur des
gestes barrières ce qui est respectée la
distanciation social porter un masque
dans les circonstances où il faut porter
un masque vous hri vous avez
l'avantagent de prendre un minimum de
temps et de diffusion dont deux mineurs
avaient pu réhabiliter la reprise du
virus dans notre prévention c'est bien
de dire puisque plus milliards d actions
que j'ai deux chargés de
l'approvisionnement en basque de la
france au gouvernement mais est ce que
imaginez s'il ya une deuxième vague est
ce qu'on pourra mettre de nouveaux 450
milliards sur la table
non écoutez je crois qu on verra mais
justement
gouverner c'est prévoir gouverner c'est
anticiper et notre rôle c'est de mettre
tout en oeuvre
pour que nous traversions cette crise en
évitant d'avoir à n'ont pas affronté une
deuxième vague mais affronter un
deuxième confinement c'est ça l'enjeu
est cet enjeu il suppose la
responsabilité tous parce que c'est le
confinement qui coûte cher mais
également de l'ensemble des acteurs et
que c'est le confinement qui butcher
tout à fait la confédération des petites
et moyennes entreprises elles elles
demandent une date pour la levée des
contraintes sanitaires dans les
entreprises pour qu' il y ait une
reprise normale
est-ce que vous entrevoyez cette date je
crois que le premier ministre a été très
clair il ya une rendez vous le 22 juin
où nous prendrons une série de mesures
sur la base des données sanitaires dont
nous disposons et vous voyez le
sanitaire il est très lié à l'économique
c'est à dire c'est ce qu'on disait un
instant c'est à dire que si le virus
circule moins on va pouvoir donner
encore plus d'espacé plus de liberté aux
différents acteurs aux entreprises donc
aux particuliers aux entreprises tout en
continuant est très stricte sur les
gestes barrières et si l'on s'aperçoit
que malgré tout il ya des signes avant
coureurs de reprise de circulation du
virus dans certains dans certaines
régions alors il faudra faire attention
moi j'ai bon espoir aujourd'hui le
déconfinement se passe plutôt bien on le
voit on voit que par rapport à il ya
trois semaines où beaucoup est inquiet
sur l'école sur la reprise du travail
sur les entreprises ça se passe bien les
choses se passent bien les entreprises
aussi pour continuer à accompagner oui
dans les entreprises je sors d'un comité
stratégique de filière par exemple avec
la filière mode et luxe j'en ai eu
quelques uns ces derniers jours et
beaucoup d'entreprises disent on n'est
pas encore au niveau d'activité de
l'année dernière mais ça se passe mieux
que ce que nous anticipions c'est à dire
pas au niveau d'activité qui et combien
de perte d'activité c'est 50 %
d'activité en moyenne non c'est beaucoup
moins au niveau industriel là on est
dans le mode et le luxe
on parle d'une activité qui est
aujourd'hui de l'ordre de 60% de
l'activité de mélanine
r et au niveau du chiffre d'affaires on
est sur une perte qui varie de 10 à 20 %
parce qu'il ya moins de fréquentation
mais les corps les gens viennent dans
les magasins c'est plutôt pour acheter
et il ya du rattrapage
on va maintenant accueillir tam traduit
de public sénat
[Musique]
surtout bon sens francis bonsoir anne
espagne et rue nash est alors en espagne
et une hache et au gouvernement vous
êtes chargé des masques on les rend
publiques des masques grand public
aujourd'hui certaines entreprises
françaises qui se sont lancés dans la
fabrication de masque en tissu 10%
avez-vous dit croule sous les stocks
est-ce que vous reconnaissez là dessus
un ratage bien au contraire je crois
qu'il faut se dire que la fabrication
des masques grand public à sauver des
centaines d'entreprises et des milliers
d'emplois
mais pour cette série il faut partir
c'est à dire que sais-je entreprises qui
n'avaient aucune activité se sont lancés
aussi dans la fabrication des masques
parce que ça leur a permis de surmonter
cette crise et aujourd'hui
depuis quelques semaines elles ont une
baisse de commandes pas tous d'ailleurs
puisque encore une fois je faisais le
point avec l'ensemble de la filière et
nous avons des données qui nous
remontent
chaque semaine on a effectivement un
stock de masques
ces masques ils peuvent être consommés
dans les grandes entreprises ils peuvent
être consommés dans les milieux de
travail et tout notre enjeu aujourd'hui
c'est de faire en sorte que plutôt que
d'utiliser comme je les ai vus
d'ailleurs ici des masques à usage
unique qui sont en règle générale
fabriqués en chine parce que surgissent
les masques dits chirurgicaux ne sont
pas tous d'ailleurs j'utilise des
masques textiles lavables fabriqué en
vacances c'est moins cher et c'est plus
écologique
est ce que vous allez fléché la commande
publique vers les entreprises françaises
ou racheter ses stocks de mac comme vous
demandent certains professionnels du
secteur
aujourd'hui j'ai lancé une mission avec
deux ambassadeurs justement pour porter
cette question de la façon dont on va
traiter la filière masque d'abord parce
qu'il faut qu'il reste une filière masse
on parlait tout à l'heure d'un risque de
circulation du virus
il faut être prêts à s'équiper et il
faut être prêt à augmenter les
productions en cas de besoin
deuxièmement nous avons et je vous
l'indiquais à l'instant des entreprises
qui aujourd'hui n'achète pas de masque
textile comme les tares l'état achète
beaucoup de masques textile les
entreprises achètent plutôt du masque
chirurgical
il faut les convaincre et c'est pas du
tout je leur renvoie pas la
responsabilité c'est un produit qui très
neuf
il faut prendre la mesure du fait que
c'est un masque de protection qui est
reconnu par les agences sanitaires
l'ansès la nsn mais du coup que ces
biens équipements de protection
individuelle et c'est là que nous
pourront écouler les stocks qui
aujourd'hui sont disponibles est-ce que
vous sortez vous en avez parlé tout à
l'heure d'une réunion avec l'ensemble de
la filière textile française est-ce que
vous avez pris des engagements pour
soutenir cette filière et notamment sur
la question des masques alors nous avons
avec brune poirson lancer une deuxième
mission qui est une mission qui vise à
construire sur toute l'énergie qui a été
déployé sur la mise en place de cette
filière masque parce que c'est un succès
il faut le dire 450 entreprises mobilisé
plus de 100 millions de masques qui ont
été fabriqués en france
d'autres qui ont été fabriqués à
l'initiative d'entreprises françaises
dans le monde et donc ce succès là c'est
un atout et il faut construire sur ça
pour développer de l'industrie textile
durable et c'est tout l'enjeu de la
mission que nous nous allons confier à
la filière textile et ce que nous
voulons c'est pas seulement des
recommandations dans quatre mois
c'est des actes c'est des mesures qui
puissent nourrir les décrets de la loi
anti gaspi de brune poirson qui puisse
permettre de mettre en place des
initiatives de relocalisation de 150
entreprises c'est important que me
suivre oui mais vous parlez de
relocalisation est il vrai que le
ministère de l'économie votre ministère
a commandé 10 millions de masques
lavables au vietnam
c'est parfaitement exact et ron nous les
avons être amendé fois au vietnam alors
plus insolvables donc tissus en tissu
réutilisables nous les avons commandées
mi-avril à un moment où nous avons
sollicité la filière textile française
qui nous a répondu qu'elle n'était pas
en situation de servir ce niveau de
production et comme nous sommes un
gouvernement responsable et que ma
responsabilité était d'équiper des
français pour le déconfinement et bien
j'ai estimé qu' effectivement il fallait
faire ce geste pour permettre aux
français d'abord c'est la pompe et
d'être équipé en masse est ce que ce
n'est pas le savez le 11 mai ça s'est
très bien passé et cette production elle
est venue complémenter la production
française qui est que tant qu'une en
france et qui était absolument incapable
de livrer ses volumes parce que c'était
le 11 mai le d'écran fouesnant mais
aujourd'hui à le faire
occurrence juin aujourd'hui elle fait
concurrence est-ce que ce message là il
n'est pas contradictoire avec le message
que veut donner aux entreprises
françaises quand vous leur demandez
d'acheter français
non pas du tout parce que précisément
l'ugap qui est la centrale d'achat
public à chaque français donc vous avez
deux mesures différentes
une mesure pour faire en sorte de
répondre à la crise et aux besoins
d'équipement des français pour le 11 mai
et il ya une commande qui est passée et
vous avez de l'autre côté
l'ugap qui est la centrale d'achat
public qui elle a passé de manière très
normal et renouvellera ses achats en
respectant le code des marchés publics
donc je rappelle que le code des marchés
publics interdit d'acheter français mais
autorise la vente village pour les
europe et ses masques qui viennent du
vietnam ils sont toujours sur le marché
en ce moment ils sont pas sur le marché
en face'' boys sont aujourd hui sur un
marché qui est beaucoup plus important
mais sont toujours en euros en
circulation ils viennent ils viennent
jédir concurrencer les masques français
pensent que vous êtes sur des niveaux
qui sont considérablement plus petits on
parle là de vous parler de 10 millions
il ya 2000 sont un million de masques
qui ont fabriqué en france
attention à pas tout mais le cordon
sécuritaire sur ces sujets là et encore
une fois
moi j'appelle solennellement les
entreprises à s'équiper en maïs ils ne
font qu ailleurs une obligation à un
moment je pense qu'on va plutôt de
travailler encore une fois on va
travailler dans la motivation va mettre
à l'obligation de vendre des engagements
au moins deux reprises de france
industrie est entraîne effectivement
j'ai eu philippe varin pas plus tard que
il ya trois ou quatre heures sur ce
sujet là et qui me disait que la
solidarité entre filières devait jouer
et qu'effectivement il fallait prendre
ce sujet et il souhaitait voir comment
les entreprises pouvaient placer des
commandes en direction des fabricants
français sur les masques français
justement est ce que vous avez eu des
remontées sur des abus de marge des abus
de prix sur ces masque en tissu dont le
prix n'est pas plafonné alors assez peu
puisque nous avons d enquête de la
direction générale de la concurrence de
la consommation et de la répression des
fraudes
on constate que pour un tiers des
masques on a un prix à usage qui varie
entre 10 et 30 centimes je rappelle que
aujourd'hui un masque chirurgical vous
le trouver dans le commerce plutôt du
côté de 60 centimes et que le prix est
plafonné à 95 centimes ils voyaient
qu'on est très loin de les plafonner
pour les masques chirurgicaux mais pas
pour la mascotte et qui suivent et les
masques textile les payes drummond sont
beaucoup moins chers ils ne venaient pas
eu de remontée de l'abus sur les prix
que vous avez moins de 5% de situations
où on a été amené à faire un procès
verbal et c'est plutôt des situations
l'information est manquante que des
situations vous avez un abus sur le prix
d'une valeur sur les masques ça a été
beaucoup critiqué la gestion des masques
il ya des commissions d'enquêté
parlementaires qui vont se mettre en
place
oui elle est commission d enquête
parlementaire vous attendent
effectivement sur ce sujet le
gouvernement est attaqué sur des
messages contradictoires qu'il a eue
qu'est ce que vous vous allez leur
répondre alors d'abord à ce stade je ne
suis pas personnellement vous êtes en
charge des masques sanitaires je pense
qu'il ya deux choses qu'il faut bien
distinguer c'est l'équipement des
soignants et l'équipement du grand
public au moment du décompte final
donc je ne me lève pas au dessus de ma
condition
mais pour reprendre répondre à votre
question je crois qu'on l'a vu tout au
long de cette crise nous découvrons les
caractéristiques du virus et le fêter
que les experts médicaux l'om est ce la
première quelle institution de référence
mondiale a eu des recommandations qui
ont varié dans le temps c'était pas
choquant puisque notre information sur
les virus a également varier dans le
temps
mais si vous vous référez et de métive
ment à ses recommandations
elles étaient plutôt négatives sur le
port du masque généralisée en début de
crise elles sont devenues ou positif
dans le courant de la crise et nous nous
sommes adaptés et ensuite
soyons clair il faut toujours balayer
devant sa porte on peut toujours faire
mieux
il y aura certainement des points et je
pense que c'est important d'ailleurs que
en interne le gouvernement lui-même
façon propre expérience parce que c'est
utile aussi j le gouvernement à propos
on veut créer sa propre enquête à propre
commission denquête avec des conclusions
qui vont aller plus vite que les deux
commissions d'enquêté parlementaires des
conclusions pour juillet est ce que
c'est une manoeuvre politique pour
couper l'herbe sous le pied non je les
parlementaires c'est une décision de
bonne gestion il s'agit simplement de
faire un retour d'expérience
mais pourquoi envers la façon dont
l'administration et dont le politique a
géré cette crise moi même j'ai fait la
crise de 2003 sur la canicule se trouve
que je travaillais à l'assistance
publique hôpitaux de paris
à ce moment là il se trouve également
que j'ai géré j'étais partie prenante de
la gestion de la crise de 2008 la crise
financière alors que j'étais à la caisse
des dépôts et consignations je peux vous
dire que ce deux expériences ont été
extrêmement formatrice pour gérer la
crise de 2002 commission n'y avait pas
de commission du gouvernement mais c'est
pas une commission c'est un retour
d'expérience c'est tout simplement la
plaie commission denquête qui souhaitent
commission d' enquête gouvernementale
sans danger recul par rapport à l'action
publique et je crois que les français je
serais très étonné que le gouvernement
n'ait pas cette capacité de recul
sensible à la danse aux enchères et
d'inter avec les parlementaires vous
entendez la tension qui est en train de
créer par avec gérard larcher qui se dit
stupéfait qui avaient cru que c'était
une fête news que le fait que le
gouvernement crée cette commission va
moi je suis très surprise parce que si
nous n'avions pas nous-mêmes travailler
à améliorer nos processus de décision
tout le monde se serait écrié que c'est
scandaleux le gouvernement aurait pu
attendre que les parlementaires rendent
d'abord sa bonne gestion et après je
veux dire il y a le temps de l'exécutif
il y a le temps des parlementaires le
fait que le bas les parlementaires sont
totalement dans leur rôle
leur rôle c'est de voter la loi et cette
contrôler le gouvernement ils le font je
le respecte parfaitement et nous
répondrons de la manière la plus
transparente possible assez commission
d' enquête parlementaire
il n'y a aucun problème mais le fait de
faire le point en interne est aussi de
bonne gestion
disons le simplement et ne mettons pas
de polémique là où il n'y a pas besoin
d'en mettre
merci tam merci fatigué à la semaine
prochaine on va faire un détour
maintenant par la rédaction du figaro
live nous est en 20100 au bon soir
vincent vous regarde évidemment tout ce
qui se passe sur sur la toile et autour
du fuyard alive qu est ce qui ressort ce
soir oui bien parmi les les informations
les plus commentés appliquée par les
internautes du figaro francis cette
petite phrase d'olivier véran sur le
déconfinement n'allons pas trop vite ça
a suscité beaucoup de critiques beaucoup
d'ironie de la part des internautes du
figaro notamment cet internaute qui lie
la france est le pays le plus touché par
la crise du pib et la hausse de la dette
mais n'allons pas trop vite
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
amis espagne et relâché alors d'abord il
est faux de dire que la france est le
pays le plus touché par la crise de la
dette et le pygmée ça c'est factuel mais
c'est pour répondre je vous réponds
factuellement seulement voilà par
ailleurs je le redis il n'y a pas une
opposition de l'objectif sanitaires et
de l'objectif économique
l'important c'est d'avoir une reprise
méthodique organisé qui permettent de
construire une reprise solide
si demain matin le virus circule ici il
faut re confiné je peux vous dire que
les mêmes commentateurs diront que nous
n'avons pas pris les bonnes mesures et
ce serait une catastrophe est en tout
cas ce serait pas bon pour l'activité
économique et ça serait pas bout
socialement et ça serait pas une bonne
nouvelle sanitaires donc soyons
méthodique organisé tenons compte de la
réalité la réalité c'est un taux de
circulation du virus c'est des éléments
qui nous remontent sur les tests s qui
sont positifs
est-ce qu'ils sont négatifs c'est une
très bonne nouvelle très bonne nouvelle
que le déconfinement se passe bien mais
ne baissons pas la garde
le virus existent il circule bien
d'autres pays nous le montre aujourd'hui
et je peux vous dire je pense que
aujourd'hui on est sur la bonne voie
continuons donc olivier ferrand et en
espagne relâché sont sur la même
longueur d'onde la la santé l'eau tu
économises yb le mans merci vincent on
va maintenant faire entrer sur ce
plateau brigitte boucher de lcp
son origine bonsoir francis von soir à
une espagnole une action soit remédié de
boucher je viens de vous entendre on
vient de parler d' olivier ferrand qui
dit n'allons pas trop vite dans
l'allègement du protocole sanitaire
quand on entend bruno le maire je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez vous on a
l'impression que ça va quand même pas
assez vite pour l'économie française
je crois car les grands enjeux c'est
effectivement d'avoir des commandes de
soutenir notre économie de faire en
sorte que la mécanique rob stein je
prends l'exemple de l'industrie le sujet
de l'industrie aujourd'hui c'est pas un
sujet de protocole sanitaire
c'est un sujet de fondamentaux
économiques
le sujet de l'aéronautique pour lequel
nous allons annoncer un plan de soutien
massif demain c'est pas un sujet de
protocole sanitaire appliquée en france
c'est le fait que le marché de
l'aviation commerciale s'est effondrée
parce que c'est ce que sa va soutenir
vous du média économique la reprise ça
va assez vite où il faudrait accélérer
je crois que il faut soutenir l'activité
du vauxhall et reese moi l'enjeu de gc
notamment et parce que j'ai aussi un
oeil sur la parité hommes femmes tout ce
qui est problématique de garde d'enfants
est important il faut que les femmes
puissent reprendre le travail que les
entrepreneurs eux puisse repasser en
posséder sûrement de pim et d'ecia des
temps c'est pour ça qu'est-ce qui vous
savez aujourd'hui plus vite
nous sommes aujourd'hui en action on
peut faire des bonds sur son siège en
disant plus vite plus vite plus vite
c'est parce qu'elle fait brigitte
l'important c'est d'avoir des
consommateurs qu'ils puissent consommer
c'est le cas aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir
des entreprises qui puisse produire
c'est le cas aujourd'hui et c'est
surtout d'avoir une vision pour la
reprise économique qui suppose d'avoir
une demande et de transformer notre
économie pour construire la croissance
suggère pour cela il faut aussi que les
jeux les enfants aillent à l'école pour
que les parents puissent retrouver le
chemin du travail
est-ce qu'il ya peint là encore on en
parlait mais il n'y a pas de ligne est
ce qu'il n'ya pas la ligne blanc caire
d'un côté la ligne vers ans de l'autre à
aucun moment je n'ai eu le sentiment que
jean michel blanquer remettiez de pied
sur le frein de la reprise dans les
économies contre eux
alors que les et verront à peut-être
envie de premiers à soutenir la reprise
dans les écoles et je rappelle aussi
qu'aujourd'hui des problématiques qu'on
a notamment à paris c'est un problème de
personnel municipal
mettons aussi les choses en perspective
on sent la candidate aux municipales à
paris deux professeurs c'est aussi un
problème de personnel qui est en appui
dans les électroménagers trois ans et
qui n'est pas s'est mobilisée par la
mairie paris qui en tout état de cause
manquent à l'appel mais bon mais
manquent à l'appel à cause de qui la
cause de qui à cause de la mairie de
paris qui fait passer ma chance ailleurs
des mes personnels municipaux donc vous
rendre au hidalgo ah ben je le renvoie
évidemment hidalgo parce que c'est elle
qui emploie ya des nouvelles règles de
chômage partiel qui sont à l'étude et
qui pourrait s'étaler sur un ou deux ans
à risque évidemment de coûter assez cher
vous vous dit banco on y va quand même
quelle est l'alternative payer du
chômage des licenciements massifs payer
du chômage ces salles alternative donc
la vraie question c'est comment fait-on
pour accompagner le plus rapidement
possible la reprise économique et dans
certaines situations effectivement
notamment dans des situations vous avez
des expertises qui sont difficiles à
reconstruire difficiles à recruter là
encore l'aéronautique est un très bon
exemple est également l'automobile vous
avez plutôt intérêt à maintenir le lien
du contrat de travail entre l'entreprise
et le travailleur à permettre parce que
le chômage partiel c'est à 0 1 ça veut
dire que vous pouvez travailler à 20% à
40% à 60% à 81 pour il aida comporte
donc à vous adapter à cela l'état
compensera mais chacun fera un effort
c'est la règle du jeu c'est la règle du
jeu qu'à poser muriel pénicaud qui me
semble une bonne règle du jeu et surtout
l'alternative c'est d'avoir des gens qui
sont au chômage et qui met du temps
alors v on disait ça coûte plus cher on
disait tout à l'heure 450 milliards la
question c'est qu'il va payer et surtout
sur certains aspects qui est quel budget
quel budget oui par exemple la dette
sociale
il ya le déficit de la sécu qui a pris
en charge une partie du chômage partiel
saaq août un déficit de la sécu à 52
milliards qui doit payer finalement
que c'est l'état est-ce que c'est
l'assurance maladie l'a déjà qui doit
payer c'est tout l'enjeu de recréer de
la croissance
je reviens toujours à ça parce que votre
principal contributeur aux impôts c'est
la croissance lorsque vous avez du
bénéfice vous avez des impôts lorsque
vous avez des gens qui travaillent
vous avez des cotisations sociales et le
vrai combat c'est celui de l'emploi et
celui de la croissance c'est le seul
combat qu'il faut mener aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on doit soutenir la demande
et on doit soutenir l'offre
on doit faire en sorte que nos
entreprises soient plus compétitives
pour aller chercher des parts de marché
à l'international
et justement être en capacité d'avoir
plus de croissance on joue et on sait de
la crise de 2008 que lorsqu'on veut
imposer une fiscalité trop rapidement on
arrête net la reprise et on le paye très
cher c'est ce que nous avons fait en
france et d'ailleurs ça a été reconnue
comme ayant un aidant ils y ont été une
erreur d'appréciation et dans les pays
européens activités proches
on n'a pas fait ça la reprise a été plus
rapide
et quand je compare le plan français au
plan étrangers moi je trouve que le
modèle allemand me paraît plutôt sérieux
et vous voyez on est à peu près sur les
mêmes dynamiques
un dernier point s'il vous plaît quand
on parle des 450 milliards on facture is
les 300 milliards de prêts garantis par
l'état
mais moi j'attends que les prêts soient
remboursés par les entreprises c'est ça
qui va financer le plan
si les réseaux entreprises remboursent
leur prêt c'est un prêt d'honneur qu'on
leur fait c'est le remboursent leur prêt
vous avez déjà 300 milliards d'euros qui
selon eex réduit la note dans ce
contexte finalement est ce qu'on peut
continuer la réforme de l'assurance
chômage ou est-ce qu'il faut
l'abandonner alors pourquoi l'abandonné
pas parce que ça coûte cher
oui vous avez dit tout à l'heure vaut
mieux vaut mieux du chômage partiel que
du chômage tout court
donc la réforme de l'assurance chômage
ne tient plus mais ça n'a juste rien à
voir l'assurance la réforme de
l'assurance chômage c'est une réforme
qui est structurel oui s'il ya du
chômage mais puisque vous devez tout
d'éviter du chômage qui vise à inciter
si je puis me permettre
qui vise à inciter justement la reprise
du travail
à date elle n'est peut-être pas adapté
dans ses fondamentaux c'est pas une
question d'argent elle n'est peut-être
pas adapté dans ses fondamentaux du rosé
avait dû au travail en son nom et elle
peut réduire les périodes
2 dans lequel on est couvert donc de ce
point de vue là on peut la suspendre
c'est ce que nous avons fait mais
pourquoi remet seulement de réformes sur
l pourquoi remettre en cause une réforme
structurelle
je ne suis pas sûr que les imams ont
nourri les martiales sur un ou deux ans
là ça veut dire que dans un ou deux ans
on peut la repousser on va pas de même
dans les médias m
jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat et pour le
prochain quinquennat le cas échéant pas
nécessairement mais je pense qu'il faut
pas confondre réformes de fond et je
veux rappeler que le bilan économique de
ce gouvernement
il a été de baisser le chômage de
plusieurs points parce que nous étions
du côté du land un contexte certes mais
ça veut dire que ce fondamentaux
structurels ont fonctionné la méthode
économique ne change pas parce que vous
avez la crise donc baisse du chômage
augmentation de la croissance en avait
une croissance de 1,5 pour cent ont été
une des plus élevées de l'europe
continentale de l'ouest
mais si on a et on a le maillot phocéen
était pardon le premier pays pour les
investissements étrangers en europe
gardons ses fondamentaux et traitons
comme nous le faisons avec méthode et
détermination le sujet m'a tout cas la
réforme de l'assurance chômage est
suspendue ce vous avez dit pour
l'instant brigitte pour continuer à
parler d'argent
on va parler parce que il va y avoir de
l'argent encore mis sur la table
et oui 40 milliards pour le troisième
budget de rectificatifs projet de loi de
finances rectificative 3,40 milliards
pour le tourisme l'aéronautique et
l'automobile 40 milliards pour pourquoi
pour boucher les trous finalement 48
heures pour préparer l'avenir
c'est toute la différence notre plan et
repose sur trois temps l'urgence d'abord
faire en sorte que les entreprises ne
tombe pas par milliers
je rappelle un chiffre les etats unis
ces 40 millions de chômeurs de plus 40
millions de chômeurs de plus est ce que
c'est ça que nous voulons pour notre
pays je ne crois pas le deuxième temps
c'est les plans de soutien c'est faire
en sorte que les entreprises qui sont
sous forte pression tiennent au moment
de la reprise
c'est ce que nous faisons pour le
tourisme pour l'automobile pour le héros
noisy c'est la recette pour les
commerçants c'est bien que le troisième
temps c'est le plan de relance et
lorsqu'on met cet argent dans la balance
en face on fait aussi des économies j'ai
parlé du chômage mais lorsque vous
remettez du fioul dans le moteur et que
vous recréez de la croissance ça fait
toute la diffusion
et c'est ce pari que nous faisons d'une
croissance qui en plus fondée sur des
fondamentaux plus écologique et plus
numérique ça alors je sais bien défendu
quoi vous avez peser sur ces 40
milliards
il ya effectivement dans toute la partie
industrielle moi j'ai pesé notamment sur
la transformation et l'accompagnement
des entreprises industrielles les
subventions à l' usine 4.0 et puis des
mesures tout simple très rapide faire
par exemple des diagnostics de reprise
des pme pour leur permettre d'accélérer
c'est tout l'enjeu de ce que nous
lançons avec bpi milian diagnostic à la
banque publique d'investissement
c'est 1000 diagnostic je dirais en blitz
famille 2000 entreprises qui auront
milroy avoir accès à un diagnostic de
l'homme ratifiés cinq jours de conseil
de la formation qui permettent à ces
entreprises de réda ouamane de
redémarrer plein pot dans l'économie en
de vie sain pour voir quels sont les
nouveaux marchés pour voir jeu vers quoi
peuvent aller c'est ça où elles sont
quelle est leur chaîne
d'approvisionnement comment elle peut
faire mieux avec 1000 entreprises l'une
ans iront de ça exactement c'est combien
ça c'est une enveloppe de combien c'est
une petite enveloppe ses 14 millions
d'euros mais c'est 1000 entreprises 1000
pme et ça leur permet d'accélérer c'est
un coup de pouce majeur dans la
croissance parce que ce dont on a besoin
c'est aussi de formation et
d'accompagnement
une dernière question de logique à la
crise a coûté cher 4 milliards dans les
transports est ce que l'état va
compenser cette somme alors l'état
aujourd'hui faire un effort massif aux
côtés des entreprises donc on n'est pas
dans des logiques de compensation on est
dans les logiques ont construit le futur
lorsqu'on accompagne l'automobile
lorsqu'on accompagne l'aéronautique
lorsqu'on accompagne des entreprises
publiques ont construit le futur
donc il y aura des partis comprendra en
charge mais pas pour tamponner mais pas
les 4 milliards en tout cas mais pour
construire le futur pas le cap milliards
ça c'est une décision qu'il appartiendra
de prendre dans les jours qui viennent
merci brigitte lissner ses profs place
maintenant d'auditions publiques à nos
invités parlementaire qui vous ont
écouté et qui nous attendent en duplex
[Musique]
ans condition publique c'est aussi le
lieu où il ya des parlementaires qui
viennent vous interroger notre invité ce
soir c'est sophie prix bas qui est
sénatrice les républicains des yvelines
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques au sénat bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous ce soir
et puis merci aussi à vous d'être avec
nous sébastien jumel vous êtes député
pcf de seine maritime et on va commencer
par sophie primas qui voudraient déjà
vous interroger sur renault parce
qu'elle incite renault chez elle vous
voyez-vous belle soie manama oui madame
la secrétaire d'état
je vous interroge évidemment comme comme
élus du département des yvelines et en
particulier d'un site dans lequel se
trouve ma commune qui est aussi le site
de leur usine renault de flins
je vous dis ça parce que dans ce site
sur lequel l'usiné est implantée depuis
1952 on à usage de dire qu'on a un
losange dans le coeur à la place du
coeur
c'est pour vous dire que nous sommes à
la fois très préoccupé par l'avenir du
groupe renault de l'alliance mais aussi
de l'industrie automobile locale qui a
façonné notre territoire d'un point de
vue social et sociologique
nous sommes des enfants de l'industrie
automobile alors la restructuration qui
a été annoncé la semaine dernière nous
laisse un petit peu sur nous sur notre
sur notre faim en particulier localement
puisqu'on nous annonce un pôle
d'excellence sur l'économie circulaire
donc sommes ravis d'être un pôle
d'excellence pourquoi pas sur l'économie
circulaire qui est une chose évidemment
stratégique d'autres acquisitions s'il
vous plaît j'arrive
mais je veux simplement dire que nous
nous refusons nous les élus locaux et
quand je parle les élus locaux c'est la
région le département et notre
communauté urbaine à ce qu'il n'y a plus
de production automobile chez renault et
à l'usiné de flins et nous sommes prêts
à investir à aider renault dans la
compétitivité comment est-ce que le
gouvernement aux côtés des collectivités
territoriales va nous aider je vous
demande de refuser le fait que nous ne
produisions plus de voitures dans notre
vallée de seine alors je crois déjà
qu'il faut poser le sujet de quoi
parle-t-on parle d'une entreprise qui
est en grande difficulté qui aborde la
crise et je crois que sophie primas est
d'ailleurs sébastien jumel puisqu'il est
également un site
sur un autre le savent très bien renault
arrive en février al'annonce de ses
résultats en disant j'ai un plan
d'économies à faire je perds beaucoup
d'argent et j'ai une situation où j'ai
des usines qui peuvent construire plus
de 5 millions de véhicules
simplement le marché n'est pas au rendez
vous sa série donc je ne pourrais pas
les vendre et j'ai un problème sophie
primas votre nom et sous le nom mais il
faut répondre à des questions je vais
répondre justement si vous me permettez
par rapport à ça la réponse c'est
effectivement de d'accompagner renault
dans son plan d'économies ce plan
d'économies
je veux le dire d'abord ce n'est pas un
plan de licenciement mer ce sont des
suppressions de postes qui vont se faire
de manière au maximum c'est l'engagement
de jean dominique senard non contrainte
juste une petite chose cela vous disiez
merci c'est ironique ou c'est sincère
non non c'est je sais tout à fait
sincère vous pourrez à travailler la
compétitivité du site pour garder
l'emploi et garder la production donc
ensuite notre enjeu à nous c'est de
positionner stratégiquement renault
comme le leader du véhicule électrique
donc toute notre vie chère des landaus
et tous justement toute la force que
nous mettons aujourd'hui dans la
bataille
c'est entre maintenant 2023 qui est la
date de 1024 en l'occurrence pour la zoé
qui est la date de fin de production de
la zoé de construire des sites pour
renault qu'ils soient tous très
compétitif je vais jusqu'au bout
lewis est tous très compétitif renommée
pas des activités de second rang dans
flins dans son plan ce des activités qui
sont essentiels lorsque renault rapatrie
par exemple le moteur électrique en
france alors qu'il devait être produit
en chine profs se sera pas d'histoires
que lyon mais ça sera un client mais
c'est pas nécessairement secondaire
lorsque renault fait comme le dit sophie
primas de l'économie circulaire c'est
pas pour une autre audition qui prime
vous opposez vous à poser toute question
secrétaire d'état vient d'elle
économique aujourd'hui de l'économie
circulaire donc ne me faites pas croire
que à date
un projet qui n'est pas construit et
dont on connaît pas le modèle économique
un drap mettre des investissements
productifs surtout surtout vous avez dit
sophie primas que les collectivités
locales la région par exemple et pas
qu'eux sont prêtes à mettre de l'argent
pour maintenir le site et sophie prix
d'amérique mais sophie primas vous dit
est ce que l'état est prêt à suivre là
dessus alors les ne pas fermer cela mais
on ne ferme pas compris on ne fait pas
la france mais on ne ferme pas flins 2
je doute que renault met en place un
modèle d'économie circulaire qui ne soit
pas soutenable c'est quand même une
entreprise automobile avec les marges
les plus difficiles je connais ce métier
j'ai été dans la sous traitance
automobile
si vous voulez si le projet ne volait
pas le mettrais pas floues faut pas
prendre les gens de renault comme et
ensuite évidemment on est prêt à
travailler main dans la main avec la
région et les collectivités locales
on le fait déjà pour mettre les
activités qui ont le plus d'avenir pour
flins pour son positionnement pour les
caractéristiques propres du site
mais est-ce que c'est d'une voiture est
ce que c'est un moteur est ce que c'est
d'autres activités c'est aux industriels
de nous faire les propositions moi moi
si je décide et zagol durand c'est
surtout à eux nous faire les
propositions lorsque l'état fait
l'industriel à la place de l'industriel
ça fait des catastrophes puisqu'on est
sur eux deux ces deux challengers au no
je suis d'accord avec sophie primas pour
dire moi je veux un modèle économique
je veux savoir combien d'emplois je veux
savoir pourquoi fait et je veux savoir
quand logan de la compét' leur renault
il ya plusieurs sites et on va retrouver
sébastien jumel parce que vous aussi
vous voulez parler de renault rno à
dieppe
mais ça c'est autre chose c'est une
autre histoire le ping si l'adn de dia
pied l'acef de la shit et duquesne et
moi je veux réagir d'abord ne pas
oublier que l'état est actionnaire et
donc l'état ne peut pas être spectateur
les décisions prises par renault mais
peut impulser une véritable stratégie
industrielle deuxième élément avoir en
tête que entre 2004 et 2009 1 nous avons
beaucoup trop des localités nous avons
renoncé à une forme de souveraineté
industrielle et l'enjeu est donc de
relocaliser des productions
en préservant l'ensemble des sites
français ce matin moi j'étais en réunion
de travail au côté de la région
du département de l'agglomération de la
ville et des industriels parce que nous
croyons en l'avenir de cette marque
premium dans une dans un site qui est
ultra moderne et dont le savoir faire
est basée sur le travail d'orfèvre des
salariés et donc ma question mais j'ai
un engagement de bruno le maire l'a tué
c'est comment l'état aux côtés de
renault mais l'état actionnaire au
moment où il signe un chèque de 5
milliards d'euros même si c'est sous
forme de prêt peut être à l'initiative
en porteur d' état stratège pour définir
une stratégie de production automobile
made in france
possible car ce que vont les erreurs
stratégiques de carlos ghosn ont été
cautionnés par l'état y compris par ses
gouvernants
alors s'agissant de renault et de dieppe
première chose je veux rappeler que
c'est précisément un état stratège que
nous agissons c'est à dire que le prêt
garanti par l'état il est conditionnée à
un certain nombre d'actions
le doublement du nombre de voitures
électriques produites sur le territoire
d'ici 2022 le quadruplement du nombre de
véhicules électriques produits sur le
territoire français d'ici 2024
le rapatriement de la production du
moteur électrique qui devait être fait
en chine sur une usine française
ça c'est très concret que les
conseillers à la maison est assorti de
centaines de millions d'euros
d'investissements
ça c'est pour la relocalisation et je
rejoins l'analyse de sébastien jumel
je me permettrai juste de dire que ce
gouvernement est le premier gouvernement
à avoir créé de l'emploi industriel en
2017 en 2018 et en 2019
ça ne s'était pas vu depuis 2000 donc là
l'industrialisation et le fait de se
battre pour chaque emploi dans une
entreprise en difficulté et le fait de
d'être à la manoeuvre localisés pour
attirer des investissements étrangers en
france et pour mettre de nouveaux sites
industriels je pense qu'on n'a pas à
rougir de notre action et nous allons
continuer au côté de renault et nous
allons continuer c'est aussi très
important surtout l'ensemble de la sous
traitance de renault parce que les deux
sujets vont de pair alors voilà c'est
une réponse directe claire et mais
sébastien jumel parler de carlos ghosn
au passage le passage de carlos ghosn ça
a été une catastrophe
je crois que là on sen
et is je sais pas combien d'années il
était à la tête de renault mais quinze
ans en une phrase qui est un peu
lapidaire et il ya une question et rio
oui je crois que tout le monde se
rappelle est d'ailleurs loué les grandes
qualités de carlos ghosn au moment il
l'a repris et restructuré nissan
notamment et sauve et nissan de la
faillite est donné à cette alliance
1 finalement une dynamique lui a permis
d'être le premier constructeur de
voitures au monde faut se rappeler de ça
après donc le bilan n'est pas mauvais
non le bilan et les contrastes et si
vous voulez vous pouvez vous résumer un
homme 20 ans de la carrière d'un homme
en une phrase lapidaire
moi je reconnais qu aujourd'hui et c'est
d'ailleurs très clairement dit par jean
dominique senard et la directrice
générale actuelle clotilde delbos
il ya une course aux volumes cette
course aux volumes
c'est une course qui a pesé sur les
fondamentaux de renault et c'était
stratégiquement une erreur dans le
reconnaît à propos de relocalisation
sophie primas vous ai écouté avec
attention parce que justement vous
dites-vous sophie primas relocalisation
d'accord mais pas n'importe quel prix et
c'est pas un jeu de mots oui non c'est
pas un changement parce que force est de
constater que nous avons depuis quelques
années orienter l'ensemble de notre
économie vers tout ce qu'on a appelé la
valeur ajoutée alors on fait plus de
recherche valeur ajoutée plus de
produits sophistiqués et en fait on
laisse une grande partie du marché le
marché qui est accessible à l'ensemble
la majorité de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens soient des produits
d'importations soit on les laisse se
délocaliser dans les pays à faible coût
comment est-ce qu'on va jouer la
relocalisation sur ses produits à faible
coût qui sont des produits essentiels à
notre économie et qui sont des produits
essentiels aussi au travail au volant du
travail question rapide réponse directe
réponse directe le premier levier c'est
l'industrie 4.0 c'est ce sont des
méthodes kobo robot fabrication additive
fabrique des machines à commandes
numériques qui peuvent faire gagner
jusqu'à 30 % de productivité à une usine
française c'est très important donc
faire baisser les prix donc permettre de
produire la même chose pour tran un prix
inférieur de d'accord pour cent ça c'est
le premier point et ça permet de
rattraper en fait
autre modèle qui est un peu plus cher il
faudra du temps pour ça il faudra
beaucoup d'années non non alors un
retour sur investissement sur un projet
d' usine du futur c'est 18 mois ça c'est
faurecia qui me le donne et c'est
d'autant plus important lorsque vous
avez des personnels dont le coût le coût
du travail dans des pays où le coût du
travail est élevé et ça veut dire aussi
beaucoup de formation puisqu'il faut
accompagner les opérateurs dans ça la
deuxième chose c'est que à la faveur de
cette crise il ya un mouvement de
relocalisation général par région donc
l'enjeu n'est plus de se comparer
forcément aux chinois ou au vietnam
mais c'est de se comparer aux portugais
et aux espagnols
on a encore de la compétitivité à gagner
mais pour gagner cette compétitivité il
faut poser la question des impôts de
production sur lequel nous sommes
sensiblement plus élevés que d'autres
pays
il faut poser la question effectivement
notre appareil de production et le
rendre plus moderne
il faut aussi essayer de trouver des
avantages compétitifs et on a des
avantages compétitifs dans nos
techniques de transition écologique
énergétique si on investit alors ce
n'est pas que de la valeur ajoutée la
transition écologique énergétique
je reprends l'exemple des masques les
masses et une fabrication assez basique
en réalité simplement la r&d très rapide
que l'on ne cherche de vos places
recherche et développement a permis de
développer des masques filtrants qui
n'existe pas beaucoup ailleurs sur le
marché européen voilà un exemple tout ça
sébastien jus que je vais je vais vous
prendre la sofipriv info que sébastien
jumel parle mais rapidement je voudrais
juste prendre au mot la ministre en
disant simplement industrie 4.0 en 18
mois on reprend la localisation de la
clio à flins et tout ira bien
ah ben si on peut le faire mais je
serais ravi mais il faut aussi aller
vous savez beaucoup des programmes c'est
à dire que pour l'avoir aussi vécu vous
avez un rythme un cycle de vie pour
savez que vous sous les 4 ans qu'on peut
bouger les pratiques tous convives a été
enregistré à l'ina on vous le ressortira
dans 18 mois
sébastien jumel puisqu'on parle de crise
vous dites vous comment on se sort de
cette crise écoutez valeur la ministre a
fait l'impasse sur le fait que ce
gouvernement avait monté le masque et
j'ai le sentiment que plus ébauche la
stratégie de relance plus les masques
tombent
l'appréhension que j'ai c'est que agnès
pannier runes h et le 10 mars dernier
nous disait c'est le moment d'investir à
la bourse parce que la bourse est solide
ce qu'elle tiendrait ses propos
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas mais que le
plan prenant sans visage et c'est que
sous la macro ni il vaut mieux être
riche et bien portant que pauvre est en
mauvaise santé et donc ma préoccupation
est la suivante chantage à l'emploi à
travers la loi pénicaud retour de la
réforme de l'assurance-chômage réforme
des retraites
actualisé mais qu'ils reviendraient sur
la table alors que ma conviction c'est
qu'il ne peut pas y avoir de relance
économique s'il n'y a pas une relance de
la demande et qui ne peut pas y avoir de
relance économique efficace et durable
sans bifurcation écologique et sans une
république sociale apaisée
autrement dit il faut le mouvement des
gilet jaune n'est pas très loin
la colère sociale et couvre il faut
rétablir des éléments justice sociale et
ma proposition que je mets sur la table
et c'est ma question à la ministre
c'est la proposition formulée avec
humanité avec sincérité par vincent
lindon new services publics sont allumés
l'injustice fiscale et est criante et
les inégalités sociales sont deux rendez
vous mettons en place une taxe valjean
c'est-à-dire prenons le pognon là où il
est ceux qui ont des yachts auront pas
de douche aux normes et peut-être
continueront à utiliser la rue haute et
finançons la relance et les services
publics et d'une certaine manière la
cohésion sociale nécessaire à la relance
avec une justice fiscale qui doit être
au rendez vous moi je j'appréhende le
fait que le monde d'avant soit comme
avant
voire pire qu'avant lorsque j'entends
ministre et et bruno le maire c'est dans
ce désert du maître vous dit il attaque
jean valjean parce que jean valjean dans
les misérables
je vais revenir de seconde sur la bourse
à ce que j'ai dit oui le regretté ce que
j'ai dit le 10 mars je voulais si je
peux aller jusqu'au bout ce que j'ai dit
le 10 mars très précisément c'est que
les entreprises françaises avaient des
monts des fondamentaux beaucoup plus
solide que ce que refléter leur valeur
en bourse donc c'était précisément pour
dire
lorsqu'on croit dans l'entreprise
française lorsqu'on croit dans nos
entreprises industrielles alors on doit
investir dans ces deux virus et donc
j'ai juste leur dire parce que ça a été
quand même effectivement et c'est
largement dans sa tombe est mal ça
tombait le jour où on parlait du
coronavirus et du début d'épidémie
donc ça faisait bizarre le coronavirus
circulait depuis quelques temps et la
bourse tombé et il fallait les cheveux
redire
nos entreprises françaises c'est elle
qui crée de la richesse c'est elle qui
donne de l'emploi
et lorsqu on soutient les entreprises on
soutient avant tout les gens qui
travaillent et dans ce pays
moi la première façon la meilleure façon
de sortir les gens de la pauvreté c'est
qu'il travaille c'est qu'ils aient accès
à leur travail sur le texte jean racine
tout l'enjeu de la taxe gens qui n'est
pas l'impôt sur la fortune c'est autre
chose ça y ressemble quand même
cruellement puisque s'était inspiré mais
c'est autre chose sur le patrimoine nous
que l'usf c'est un pourcentage sur les
patrimoines donc appris laissez pas la
même c'est pas le même pourcentage c'est
pas forcément la même page plus élevés
et sur des pattes alors qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ça je répondrai
simplement que lorsqu on lit l'histoire
des misérables jusqu'au bout et c'est
cette partie et cette facette de jean
valjean que je préfère il devient
monsieur madeleine et monsieur madeleine
ils montrent d'abord une fabrique de
verroterie puis il devient un industriel
reconnu et enfin il s'engage comme maire
auprès de ses compatriotes et c'est
comme ça qu'il fait en sorte que tous
les gens autour de lui et un emploi est
liée particulièrement attentifs et cette
facette de jean valjean me semble
beaucoup plus intéressant alors que
l'idée de taxer systématiquement en
l'occurrence le capital c'est à dire ce
dont on a besoin parce que les mêmes qui
nous disent mais taxer le capital c'est
tellement simple nous disent aussi il
faut renforcer les fonds propres des
entreprises
mais c'est quoi les fonds première le
merci sébastien jumel qui vous écoute
parce que si ça leur jean valjean gens
regardent dans le genre hal jordan
espionnage et c'est pas le même que le
vôtre c'est possible et c'est lui-même
pourtant ça donne à vous et à vous
j'imagine bien que dans le 16e
arrondissement de paris on ne rencontre
pas les mêmes ravages en que dans ma
cité portuaire et populaire de diem moi
je crois en intelligence ouvrière je
crois aussi que nous avons
rendu hommage aux premiers corvée qui
ont fait en sorte que l'économie tourne
pendant le coronavirus et je pense que
la moindre des reconnaissances c'est là
que j'entends parler de relance par la
demande
c'est d'envisager une meilleure
reconnaissance par le salaire c'est
d'envisager que la pénibilité de ces
métiers là soient reconnus et qu'on ne
revienne pas en deuxième lecture sur la
loi des retraites parce que nous savons
que les premiers core v n'ont pas les
mêmes points de vie en bonne santé que
ceux qui vivent dans le luxe calme et la
volupté et que lorsque j'entends parler
d'une réforme de l'assurance chômage qui
viserait en fait à réduire le coût
d'indemnisation
je suis inquiet sur votre conception à
des misérables parce que je vous le dis
madame la ministre
il y à une colère rampante qui couvre le
sentiment d'avoir le sentiment fort que
le confinement n'a pas été le même pour
tout le monde et que le décompte
finement n'est pas le même à leur monde
à nice rémy relâcher alors chacun de son
design espagne et rue lâché chacun son
histoire mois il se trouve que je
connais bien les chantiers navals de la
ciotat
c'est quelque chose qui a je dirais
bercé mon enfance dans ton cas chantier
chantier ennemis
et par ailleurs là où je partage c'est
que l'enjeu aujourd'hui que nous avons
par rapport aux classes populaires et je
rappelle que les classes populaires
nous sommes les premiers à avoir baissé
les impôts des gens qui sont de ces
classes populaires qui sont des classes
moyennes parce qu'ils travaillent et qui
paient beaucoup d'impôts la baisse de 5
milliards de l'impôt qu'elle me disiez
jeu sébastien jumel qui j'ai lu la
version allemande et française transmise
aujourd'hui aux membres de la commission
économique du plan de relance en
allemagne et le levier des allemands
c'est d'agir sur la tva l'impôt le plus
injuste de situer les marges des
entreprises faut lire le plan jusqu'au
beau c'est pas pour baisser les prix
donc je vais aller jusqu'au bout et
c'est que l'enjeu pour les personnes de
ces premiers de corvée comme vous dites
c'est effectivement améliorer les
conditions de travail
ça c'est un enjeu c'est de faire en
sorte que leur enfant est accès aux
meilleures études ça c'est ce que nous
faisons en dédoublant les classes moi je
préfère être dans un monde
on dit aux gens on vous donne les moyens
de réaliser votre potentiel d'avoir un
emploi que vous méritez de pouvoir
progresser
plutôt que de le redistribuer de manière
je dirais quasiment facile prenez
l'argent et puis ça ira bien et puis
vous n'aurez pas d'avenir mais salut aux
graves devrait un peu d'argent pour
survivre on va finir de jean valjean un
zoo humain
sophie primas une dernière question très
rapide à propos d'avenir et et
d'environnement justement oui je
voudrais simplement c'est presque une
supplique à madame la secrétaire d'état
dans la transition écologique on voit
bien et je pense que la crise a été un
formidable accélérateur que cette
transition écologique elle est
importante elle est importante pour les
français elle est importante pour les
entreprises c'est probablement à un
levier de relance
est ce que vous pourriez faire un plan
non hystériser et qui soit un plan dans
lequel on ait une vision de long terme
on peut pas dire il faut plus de
voitures et faire un plan relance
automobile
on peut pas dire il faut de l'énergie
décarbonée et arrêter complètement le
nucléaire il faut pas dire qu'on veut
consommer de l'agriculture alors ne pas
soutenir les agrocarburants et c'est un
plan qui soit donné series et à long
terme agnès pèlerinage est alors
rapidement
moi je crois que l'enjeu c'est
effectivement d'avoir une approche qui
soient pragmatiques de l'écho
j'ai une approche pragmatique de
l'écologie c'est justement on ne dit pas
il faut zéro voiture on dit il faut des
voitures qui polluent moins c'est tout
l'enjeu de la prime à la conversion
lorsqu'on dit changer votre voiture qui
a 15 ans d'âge qui polluent beaucoup
pour une voiture qui à en croire un
moteur thermique mais qui polluent dix
fois moins eh ben on est pragmatique
comme ça que nous devons construire le
plan la réponse est claire merci sophie
primas merci sébastien jumel d'avoir été
avec nous en direct dans audition
publique on va accueillir maintenant il
est temps yves thréard
bonsoir yves bonsoir francis bonsoir
madame c'est le regard palier yves
thréard une hache et alors vous avez
fait beaucoup de technique là pendant
trois quarts d'heure faire un peu de
politique
on a on regarde un petit peu ce qui se
passe le spectacle donné par la majorité
présidentielle et puis alors vous êtes
arrivé il ya trois ans la majorité on
était en marche
on a un peu l'impression qu'elle est en
morceaux là non je crois que s'expriment
effectivement un certain nombre de
tendances mais c'est amusant parce que
finalement quand on est à rosas désarroi
zan quand on est arrivé il ya trois ans
on parlait des godillots
ba aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
députés témoigne de l'intérêt de
diverses d'importance du vergeroux même
carrément non diverses
parce que quand vous votez des projets
je vous invite à le regarder on retrouve
manifestement une majorité une majorité
assez large se réduit comme peau de
chagrin
oui mais ce qui est important c'est les
majorités de projets autour des textes
de loi et moi j'ai pas eu pour avoir
porté le pélé ferrain le plfr 2 par
exemple donc les projets de loi de
finances que gfi cative travail qu'on a
fait par exemple dans ce plan d'urgence
il ya eu une certaine adhésion à la
démarche que nous avions mis en place le
groupe majoritaire à l'assemblée
nationale est dirigée présidé par gilles
legendre qui a commis récemment une note
qui a été rendue publique dans laquelle
il n'a pas des mots très agréable pour
le premier ministre il y dit même qu'il
faut le changer
et puis il veut faire un grand ménage
ministériel vous approuvé cette démarche
alors c'est pas à moi qui suis membre du
gouvernement de commenter une note qui
au passage il revient ministre lui
d'ailleurs c'est le seul parlementaire
qui se verrait bien ministre
je pense qu'il ya d'autres
parlementaires qui pourraient se voir et
lui il suggère ces accords il donne sa
candidature et le remaniement c'est le
président de la république il décidera
au temps où il voudra à le dessiner et
en faisant confiance au premier ministre
qu'il aura choisie ou renou en conforter
il commet une faute
j'ai legendre je crois surtout que
c'était un papier confidentiel et je
m'étonne de le retrouver dans la presse
mais après c'est peut-être par
l'opposition qui l'a rendu public ce le
sujet n'intéresse pas les français enfin
les commentateurs certainement mais les
français ce qui les intéresse c'est de
savoir si le 22 juin le confinement va
être élargie et si leur emploi est ce
que au pompage et un gendre doit
démissionner de son poste de président
de l'assemblée nationale laissons-lui
discuter laissons-lui discuter avec le
groupe et c'est certainement pas au
pouvoir exécutif et a fortiori un
secrétaire d'état de commenter ce que
doit faire le groupe majoritaire à la à
l'assemblée nationale demain il ya dû y
avoir un petit déjeuner ils étaient
annulés qui déjeuner de la majorité à
cause de cela je pense que c'est le
temps de la discussion vous savez à un
groupe ça s'organise dans la discussion
dans la confrontation parfois c'est
important d'avoir quelqu'un qui anime le
groupe
c'est agile et à ses collègues de
prendre ce moment et de s'expliquer et
je crois pas que mais il doit
s'expliquer gilles aujourd'hui à 6 doit
s'expliquer j'ai les jambes doit
s'expliquer gilles legendre je crois
qu'il doit prendre le temps oui de la
discussion mais comme ils l'ont de
l'explication
s'expliquer sur cette note on titille
sur les mots franchement c'est pas une
question très intéressant alors il est
beaucoup question d'un acte iii est ce
qu'on peut faire un acte iii de ce
quinquennat puisqu'il ya eu là que 1
c'était l'arrivée l'acte 2 après les
gilet jaune
acte iii peut-être après cette pandémie
est-ce qu'on peut le faire avec le même
premier ministre
ce qui est important c'est de savoir
quelle est la vision la vision que nous
voulons porter dans les 18 mois qui nous
séparent ou les weir vous soyez plus
sociale mais je pense qu'on a besoin de
visibiliser tout le travail que nous
avons fait dans le domaine social la
partie économique est bien visible
elle est appréciée elle est remarquée à
l'international elle est valorisée à la
droite mais la gauche n'a pas l'air de
suivre
pardon un moyen de gégé longtemps voté à
gauche et je valide totalement le plan
économique qui a été fait parce que ce
plan économique c'est la vraie façon ce
qu'il faut de régler la question sociale
c'est en redonnant un emploi aux gens
maintenant ils social alors il faut
c'est pas qu'il faut le faire
ça fait trois ans qu'on le fait ça fait
trois ans qu'ils aient un plan pauvreté
ça fait trois ans qu'on a mis en place
des dispositifs complémentaires pour
faire en sorte que les gens puissent
avoir le destin qui mérite que l'on à
des doublés par exemple les classes pour
les erp etc pour prendre que cet exemple
là qu'elle est la plus grande injustice
sociale en france or c'est l'école par
d'accord c'est l'école c'est le fait que
en france vous mais génération pour
changer de csp alors qu'ailleurs c'est
deux à trois générations madame figaro
madame tia paquet au gouvernement avec
avec vous fait savoir qu'elle aimerait
bien changer de poste avoir un poste
plus important alors qu'elle est chargée
de l'égalité entre hommes et femmes est
ce que ça serait votre cas vous si vous
êtes secrétaire d'état auprès de
monsieur darmanin monsieur le maire ce
qui doit pas être tous les jours facile
d'ailleurs mais ce que vous voudriez
prendre davantage de place à l'intérieur
avec le gouvernement en l'occurrence je
suis secrétaire d'état auprès de
monsieur le maire uniquement lui
moi je m'épanouis beaucoup dans ce que
je fais et comme toujours
comme toute personne qui s'épanouit dans
son poste j'aspire à prendre plus de
responsabilités parce que les
entreprises c'est passionnant parce que
dans le domaine économique ou dans un
autre ministère
écoutez c'est pas moi qui fais la
feuille de match
et qui dit qui doit être défenseur et
qui doit être attaquant et je fais
confiance au président de la république
pour choisir le bon défenseur et le bas
n'avaient plus de responsabilités aux
responsabilités ça vous êtes prêté à
l'assumer mais je pense que de manière
générale mes collègues et moi-même
aspirons pour ceux qui veulent rester au
gouvernement c'est à dire qu'on passait
un cycle complet et certains ont une
bouée le lendemain à avoir plus de
responsabilités rester légitime avec
moins de ministres
par exemple moi je me vois très bien
rester au gouvernement si le président
de la république m'a fait qu est ce qu
il faut restreindre le nombre de
ministres et de secrétaires d'accord une
fois faut partir de la vision moi je
commence pas pour avoir été en charge
d'un certain nombre de personnes dans
des entreprises par exemple vous posez
la vision stratégique
vous posez la façon d'y aller et ensuite
vous prenez la meilleure vue demander
moins de ministres éventuellement et
plus de responsabilité pour les uns et
les autres jeux j'ai pas d'idée a
particulièrement reçues sur ce sujet là
je peux pas recentré un peu le robinet
on peut être un pack en étant nombreux
l'important c'est l'animation aussi
gouvernemental c'est les projets qu'on
veut porter c'est la façon dont on veut
porter les projets et seule une fois
c'est pas une question de nombre
je suis fasciné par la tension qu'ont
les gens au casting alors que pour moi
l'enjeu c'est des êtres et le projet
laisser des hommes et les femmes
est ce que c'est
dérangeant que le premier ministre soit
plus populaire que le président de la
république dans ces conditions là c'est
plutôt rassurant d'avoir une équipe
gouvernementale qui a marqué des points
ces dernières semaines je crois que
avoir un premier ministre qui à ce stade
2 et au-delà de 50% c'est plutôt
rassurant sur l'action gouvernementale
c'est anormal et vous êtes aussi
candidate osé parler d' anne hidalgo la
présélection municipal dont le deuxième
tour aura lieu à paris aussi le 28 juin
vous avez parlé de madame hidalgo tout à
l'heure
il faut l'abattre non je crois que c'est
mauvais ça politique
alors vous avez plusieurs choses moi je
ne me reconnais pas dans le projet
d'anne hidalgo je ne me reconnais pas
rachida dati dans le projet d'anne
hidalgo j'ai pas de problème souvent
avec les têtes de chapitre
j'ai un problème avec l'exécution c'est
à dire que je prends le bilan qui a été
de ces six dernières années et je trouve
qu'il ya un écart sensible entre la
promesse et la réalisation
je suis désolé mais ça on a un bilan
c'est pas le cas de rachida dati ou en
tout cas on assure une petite mairie
n'ont fait difficile de prendre position
mais pour madame hidalgo on a un bilan
il n'est pas satisfaisant votre visa de
sa nièce rachida dati si vous voulez je
ne me reconnais pas dans son projet je
dire la propreté et la sécurité
franchement ça fait marrer et donc je me
reconnais dans le projet d'agnès b
inquiète un projet du de quelques jours
où vous avez interrogé sur sur agnès
buzyn ou tour dit un peu le nez vous
ultime date et satisfaite qu'elle
revienne leur jeu pas du tout alors vous
êtes à 300 % derrière elle
je suis à 300 % derrière elle j'ai un
grand respect pour cette dame pense que
l as raison de conduire et de poursuivre
la campagne et moi je pense que son
projet est le projet que nous avons
construit collectivement qui est un
projet marcheurs qui est un brochet dans
lequel nous avons justement vocation à
incarner cette troisième voie c'est quoi
cette troisième voie c'est d'être
pragmatique dans l'écologie ce dernier
point pas très ternes à paris ça je suis
d'accord c'est un arrondissement
compliqué c'est l'alliance qui m'a le
plus agréable mais re qui vient de l erc
a passé chez vous la république en
marque finalement elle revient à
santander jamais fait les deux ce vous
trouvez ça normal
écoutez de deux choses l'une soit elle
soutient agnès buzyn troisième tour et
j'arrêterai de tordre le nez soit ce
n'est pas le cas je serais déçu vous
êtes très des cieux pour ça je serais
déçu c'est pourquoi tant de troisième
tour l'élection du maire ça que ça se
jouera aussi la merci merci vraiment
d'avancé on a déjà parlé du troisième
tour vous imaginez merci beaucoup il
c'est la fin d'audition publique en
espagne et rue nash et merci d'être
resté avec nous pendant une heure en
direct live accès à un script et de
débattre aussi avec les parlementaires
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission sur figaro live ainsi que
sur les comptes twitter de lcp public
sénat
et auditions publiques revient lundi en
direct à 19h bonne soirée
non